enter into inter-institutional
negotiations pursuant
to rule 71 paragraph one announced at
the opening of the session last monday
the president has received no request
for a vote in parliament by members or
political groups reaching at least the
medium threshold so the committees may
therefore start
the negotiations
we move now
to the key debate the next item on
the agenda
is european council
council and commission statements
conclusions of
the european council meeting of the 24th
and 25th of march 2022
including the latest developments of war
against ukraine and the eu sanctions
against russia and their
implementation
just by way of reminder
dear colleagues we are testing some of
the recommendations of the
focus group on plenary reform and
therefore there is free seating applied
for
all the plenary chamber with the
exception of the first
two rows that is allocated to group
leaders
and you will be able to request the
catch ti and blue cards uh via your
voting machine after having inserted
your voting card and therefore i invite
you always to bring your voting card
into
uh the hemi cycle uh in fact if you
would like to register for catch the eye
for this debate i
invite you to start doing that
from now
also following the recommendation
of the focus groups the speaking time
are located for all interventions will
be now minimum
two minutes and this also applies uh for
the catch ti
as well
if you are going to use a blue card you
can do that for a short
uh
intervention and that will allow for a
follow-up question all the speeches will
take place from the central uh lectern
except for the catch the eye blue cards
and point of order with that we start
the debate and i invite the president of
the european council charles michelle to
take the flawed
they are members of the european
parliament
just two weeks ago
in this parliament
we expressed our shock and horror
the martyrdom of mario paul
crimes against the city
crimes against its people
and today
we express our outrage
at crimes against humanity
against innocent civilians
in butcher
and in many other cities
yet more proof
that russian brutality against the
people of ukraine has no limits
yet more proof of war crimes
summary executions
bodies littered in the streets
mass graves
this is not
a special operation
these are war crimes
and
we the eu
we will not turn our backs
we will look reality
straight in the eye
there must be
and there will be severe consequences
for all those responsible
and we are already supporting all
efforts to collect the evidence
we will do everything
everything we can to bring the
perpetrators to justice
international justice will be served
and dear colleagues
i have one message
for the russian soldiers on the
battlefield
if you want no part
in killing
your ukrainian
brothers and sisters
if you don't want to be a criminal
drop your arms
stop fighting
leave the battlefield
and i know their colleagues their
members of the parliament some of you
have suggested
granting asylum for these russian
soldiers who disobey russian orders in
my opinion this is a valuable idea that
should be pursued
dear colleagues
dear colleagues right now
we must do everything to make these
atrocities stop
we are toughening our sanctions
to keep and to exercise maximum pressure
on the kremlin
and during our last european council
meeting we tasked the high
representative and the commission to
propose additional sanctions to council
we must close the loopholes we must
target any attempts to circumvent
sanctions and we are ready to move
quickly with further coordinated robust
sanctions
the new package includes a ban on coal
import
and ladies and gentlemen
i think i think that measures
on oil
and even gas will also be needed sooner
or later
we will stop russian vessel from
entering eu ports and impose a ban on
russian and belarusian road transport
operators
will impose a full transaction ban on
more russian banks to further weaken
russia's financial system and we will
coordinate
with our friends from the g7
organization
ladies and gentlemen president biden and
president zlensky joined our last
european council meeting president
biden's presence
and presidency's address sent a clear
message
that autumn's atlantic partnership
and our support for ukraine is work
solid
we are more united than ever
united in sanctioning russia
united in putting pressure on the
kremlin united in supporting ukraine as
much as we can
we know we are in this for the long haul
with the united states canada japan
australia the republic of korea the uk
and many countries and france around the
world
we are ready to bear the costs of
sanctions and most importantly
our unity
our eu unity out in the atlantic unity
our determination
these are our main assets to end the war
to stop these atrocities and to help
rebuild ukraine
we will continue to assist ukraine with
political financial humanitarian and
material support we have agreed to
develop a ukraine solidarity trust fund
in the short term it will help support
the state of ukraine in the long term it
would provide massive investments to
rebuild the economy and infrastructure
ladies and
gentlemen this war is
a human tragedy
over 10 million people have fled the war
in ukraine more than 6 million are
internally displaced while over 4
million have fled to the eu mostly women
and children
we are welcoming them with dignity and
with solidarity
because the ukrainian people deserve our
support we will continue to offer them
any assistance they need such as housing
education health care and we will pay
special attention to the most vulnerable
women children who could fall prey to
traffickers
the stand-up for ukraine pledging event
in warsaw on saturday will help raise
money and other support for refugees and
internally displaced people
i would like to express my gratitude to
all and especially to the countries
bordering ukraine for the solidarity
poland slovakia hungary romania moldova
ladies and gentlemen
rarely
has the contrast between right and want
being so stark
the war in ukraine is a moment of truth
and urgency for europe
today
european
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you very much president
michelle i now
invite on behalf of the council of the
high representative joseph
honorable members
i have the honor of participating in
this debate representing
the council
the council of the union
since the high representative has the
honor of chair
the two formations of the country
related with
foreign affairs and security and defense
allow me to continue in spanish
security security defense
political
michelle
diplomatically
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
gracias
thank you very much
hi representative borel i now invite
the president of the european commission
ursula on the line to take the floor
thank you madam president dear roberta
mr president dear charles hi
representative dear
joseph honorable members
only seven weeks ago
which i was a friendly
and quiet suburb on the outskirts of
keefe
but last week humanity itself was killed
in butcher
it was killed in cold blood
executed with his hands tight and a
bullet in the head
it was left to rot in the middle of the
street or in mass graves
we have all seen the haunting images of
butcher
and we've heard the testimonies of those
who speak freely again now that the
russian army has left they shot everyone
they saw one witness said about putin
soldiers
this honorable members is what is
happening when putin's soldiers occupy
ukraine territory they call it
liberation
no we call it war crimes and we really
have to give it this name
the european union has set up a joint
investigation team with ukraine to
collect evidence and testimonies on the
ground
we will hold accountable those who are
responsible for war crimes the
perpetrators must pay
after butcher
more than ever europe stands firmly with
ukraine
we stand with ukrainians in their
devastated cities and their bomb
shelters
we stand with them in their parliament
surrounded by sandbags and barricades
we stand with the millions who flee the
invaders
and we will do everything and our power
to ensure that they can return home
safely
and this is the message hrvp borrel
and i will bring to president zelinski
when we will be visiting keith at the
end of this week
at this critical point in the war
we must increase the pressure on putin
again and the russian government
and this is why we propose to tighten
our sanctions even further
the fifth package
has six pillars
first we impose an import ban on coal
from russia
worth 4 billion euros a year
finally it was high time to do this step
it's the first time that we directly
sanction the import of fossil fuels from
russia thus cutting an important revenue
source
second a full transaction ban on four
key russian banks among them vtb
the second largest russian bank
these four banks which we now totally
cut off the markets
represent 23 percent of the market share
in the russian banking sector
this will again weaken russia's
financial system
third
a ban on russian vessels and
russian-operated vessels from accessing
eu ports
additionally we will propose a ban on
russian and belarusian
road transport operators
this will ban
drastically this ban will drastically
limit the options for russian industry
to obtain key goods
and the fourth and the fifth measure are
important exports
further targeted export bands with 10
billion euros in areas where russia is
vulnerable
from quantum computing to advanced
technology semiconductors machinery
transport
equipment with this we will continue to
degrade russia's technological base and
industrial capacity
fifth
specific new import bands were 5.5
billion euros to cut the money stream of
russia and its oligarchs on products
from wood to summit from seafood to
liquor
in doing this
we also close the loopholes between
russia and belarus
and the sixth measure is very targeted
measures such as a general ban on
participation of russian companies in
any kind of public procurement in the
member states or an inclusion exclusion
of all financial support be it a
european level be it at member states
level to russian public bodies
because honorable members
european taxpayers money should not go
to russia in whatever shape or form
and therefore we have to be
tough on the measures we have to be
consistent in the sanctions we have to
be ins increasingly gradually stepping
up our sanctions are hard because they
limit the kremlin's political and
economic
options they are smart because they
affect russia much harder than us
and honorable members these sanctions
will not be our last sanctions as i said
already yesterday yes we've now banned
coal but now we have to look into oil
and we'll have to look into the revenues
that russia gets from the fossil fuels
and we really have to make an effort for
example to take a share to the escrow
to an escrow banking system so that we
will really limit the source of revenues
from russia from
from fossil fuels it has to be an end
with that and this is the next step we
have to take together
more than 40 countries are playing
sanctions like these
and we expect others to respect our
measures or at the very least
not to circumvent
and undermine our sanctions
and this was our message to china
at our summit last friday
we made clear how crucial it is for us
in europe but also for the rest of the
world to take a clear stance
a clear stance against putin's war of
choice
against the massacres of civilians
against this violation of the
fundamental principles of the world
order
and as a permanent member of the u.n
security council china has a special
responsibility to uphold international
peace and security
and nobody can be neutral when faced
with such naked aggression against
civilians this is not a war limited
to europe which russia has unleashed
this will also define how we globally
treat such violence of international law
in the future and also china has to take
a clear stance on that
honourable members
europe today is more resolute than ever
to stand for the principles we cherish
most
and to this aim
we also must protect ourselves from
knock-on effects of this war
this is true for energy
we have to get rid of our dependency of
fossil fuels and for that we also have
to diversify away from russia
building on the work of the eu euro
energy council
president biden and i have just launched
another agreement
and this is threefold first
on the supply side
the u.s provides us with at least
additional 15 billion cubic meters of
lng gas this year
this gives us the opportunity to replace
the russian lng this year
second for the coming years we're aiming
for at least an additional 50 billion
cubic meters annually
this will give us the opportunity to
replace at least one third
of the russian pipeline gas arriving in
europe
and the third is we focus together on
building a greener future with climate
neutrality the one goes with the other
we engage with our energy industry the
energy intensive industry to further
reduce the demand this is existential
that we look at the energy efficiency
and it is good news that the
infrastructure we use for gas today can
also be used to repurpose for clean
hydrogen in the future
thus
the us and the european union have not
only worked closely together on
designing an effective and determined
response to russia's war
but we are also supporting each other in
the transition towards a green energy
honourable members
in these dark times
there's one thing that truly makes me
proud
people
in every corner of our union
have rolled up their sleeves
to help our ukrainian friends in need
right now
more than 10 million ukrainians are
either internally displaced or seeking
shelter abroad
this is a quarter
of the ukrainian population
the bulk of this work is carried out by
local authorities
it's carried out by citizens
this is why we front loaded 3.4 billion
euros in cohesion funds to address the
most urgent needs this means classrooms
hospital beds employment support in the
regions that are hosting the largest
numbers of ukrainians
and here
the polish people are amazing
the entire country is standing in
solidarity with their ukrainian guests
this is why together with prime minister
justin trudeau of canada
we are convening a pledging event for
ukraine and warsaw
next saturday for ukrainian refugees in
ukraine and outside ukraine
president duda is joining us
we call our campaign stand up for
ukraine
and we'll do it together with the
international advocacy organization
global citizen
we will mobilize support for people
fleeing the invasion of ukraine
together with us
citizens sports people civil society
artists
like bono u2 madonna or chris
will stand up for ukraine
they will call on governments
they will call on the business community
to join our efforts
the brave people of ukraine deserve
solidarity from all around the globe
slava ukrainia long live europe
thank you very much president wander
lyon and i now invite representatives of
the different political groups to take
the floor starting with the epp group
mumford weber
and